powerful statement from jj watt after
the
texans lost on sunday to the cincinnati
bengals and that that's that
sentiment will resonate extremely well
in the locker room of the next team jj
watt plays for cause i just think it's a
matter of time before he's no longer a
houston texan it's airing of grievances
time chris i'm going to throw it to you
and and uh you you've got one
that has legs this time of year i'll let
you take it from here well we hit on it
last week a little bit right and you
know it was the holidays maybe not
everybody saw it but i think it's even
more prevalent this week with what we
got going on
the the race for the number two seed you
know i think that was one of the
unforeseen circumstances or you know the
thing that maybe the nfl didn't plan for
but man this week would be a whole lot
better if we had the race for the number
two seed and that first round by two
i mean pittsburgh and buffalo wouldn't
be talking about wrestling players right
now that would not be a conversation
they'd be trying to play to have a real
week off and then of course only have to
play two games so i think that's one of
those things where you know it's
disappointing
it really is you know and even it hurts
in the nfc i know we still have those
three teams towards the top there but it
would still add intrigue to know okay
how does this shake out on sunday and
which of the two out of the three the
saints the seahawks or the packers get
those first round buys that would be
something there to that so you know
again i didn't love this 17 playoff
format i did not love it and this is one
of the things i didn't really think of
at the time
but yeah that bothers me and you know
we're gonna go to eight eight teams
and then what have more irrelevant games
in week 17 i mean if we went to eight
teams mike next year which i mean or
it's coming soon we know
arizona wouldn't be playing this week
that would take another game off the
list i mean i just to me again i wish we
could go back to six
there's always going to be the scramble
for the last spot whether it's four five
six seven or eight and in my lifetime
it's been four it's been five it's been
six and now it's been seven per
conference there's always a scramble for
that last spot that's always going to be
there you're just moving where it is but
when you take off the table the chase
for the two seed and the bye week that
goes along with it you inherently make
the process less interesting and we've
got this cluster in both conferences of
two through six and nobody knows and
nobody cares there's too many moving
pieces there's too many moving parts
it's too hard to figure it out let's
just see how it plays out i agree with
you i'm reluctant to do so but i agree
with you it's more fun when there's two
buys you've got more for the best teams
to play for and it would be great to see
this game of musical chairs between
seattle green bay and new orleans for
two
spots
with a week off yeah and one team is
gonna have to play next week so uh and
and yeah when it goes to eight then
the only thing left is that that race
for the eighth seat everybody else is in
and it's just okay well you're the
division winner you're the wild card and
look home field advantage means even
less this year when there aren't fans
there so this this is the worst possible
year to go to seven frankly the way that
it's all played out but but it is
something for the nfl to think about
because
the playoffs at the top are less
exciting yes the race for the playoffs
is less exciting than it's ever been and
that's because there's only one by now
instead of two here's mine yeah um
and and and this is a plea
to everyone out there who covers the nfl
just because you get a press release
doesn't mean that you just
vomit that press release all over your
social media accounts or wherever just
so you can check the box and say you've
reported something or for some people i
think there's a little mamu involved for
the things that they promote when the
press release rolls around but yesterday
this idea that russell o'coon gets paid
in bitcoin
got legs because ian rappaport tweeted
he gets paid in bitcoin
except he doesn't get paid in bitcoin
and rap report eventually tried to put
the toothpaste back in the tube
with this long convoluted tweet that
basically was saying he doesn't get paid
in bitcoin and he doesn't get paid in
bitcoin he gets
his money into an account right just
like anybody else and he buys bitcoin
with it he's not being paid in bitcoin
and it was a ruse by whoever it is that
wants people to go out and this whole
bitcoin look i i gladly don't understand
it because in my gut it tells me it's
it's one big pyramid scam that's what it
is and somebody's getting screwed when
they buy bitcoin but this idea that he's
being paid in bitcoin i was like oh they
paying bitcoin now no they don't no they
don't yeah and that drove me nuts
yesterday and and and again it's it's
grievance time and i feel better mike it
was therapeutic for me well good i i
when i read it yesterday on pft i was
like wait the nfl let this go i thought
like did i oh they did it it didn't
happen i was like the nfl is gonna let
teams play players in bitcoin now i mean
whoa the salary cap's gonna get really
interesting so i i was shocked when i
saw that
it was all false it was all fake and it
was all calculated
to get people to think
that bitcoin is some bigger deal than it
is so they'll go buy bitcoin and the
value goes up and up and up and then you
get out and let the suckers who got in
late
hold the bag
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports